Jonathan hunt is there right now with
the very latest Jonathan Neil hard to
think of a more spectacular way to kick
off America's July 4th weekend here at
the iconic Mount Rushmore you can see it
right behind me later this evening we
will have a fly pass by Air Force One as
the president comes in to land at nearby
Ellsworth Air Force Base then Marine 1
will also fly past as he comes back to
land right here but this is not just
about celebration tonight obviously in
these times there is always politics
with it part of the politics here
coronavirus the governor of South Dakota
said there is no social distancing
required we can tell you that having
seen the chairs they are not separated
by a single inch and some of the benches
below me are also filling up now I'd say
Neil from my view maybe 2030 percent of
people are wearing masks but they are
not required to officials are handing
out masks if people want them but by no
means is it a requirement for attending
this event then you mentioned the
fireworks they are there they were
stopped after 2009 because if I works
had caused nearby forest fires the South
Dakota governor Kristi Noem said that
when she took office that she wanted to
bring them back president Trump
enthusiastically endorsed that saying
what's there to burn it's just stone
well there's a lot of stone here there's
also a great deal of forest so there are
firefighting units on hand a
strategically-placed should there be any
issue with that there's also the
question of this land Neil and Sioux
tribe members plan to protest on the
roads leading up to Mount Rushmore today
because they say this land is rightfully
theirs and should be given back to them
finally Neil we have the politics of
President Trump's speech we're going to
get fireworks after that literally we
may have figurative fireworks are in the
President's speech and to return to the
theme of coronavirus Neil's stage behind
me here has a couple of video screens
either side of it they've been popping
up warnings about dehydration
mornings about ticks being prevalent in
the area warnings about sunburn one
thing they haven't mentioned coronavirus
Neal